et nous recevons à présent sur ce
plateau notre journaliste sportif
michael elle me d'euros pour la
traditionnelle chronique sport du joli
bonsoir à vous amis quel danseur florane
ravi de vous retrouver pour ce moment et
bien merci que le thème de votre
chronique d'aujourd'hui
alors sortez votre panama et vos
lunettes de soleil floral aujourd'hui je
vous emmène du côté de la porte
d'auteuil l'un des tournois de tennis
les plus prestigieux au monde a débuté à
dimanche dernier je vous parle bien sûr
de roland garros floral les chiffres de
ces internationaux de france on vous
donnait le vertige 128 joueurs et
joueuses quatre cent mille spectateurs
1300 journalistes
près de 4500 raquette 45 tonnes de terre
battue 66000 petite balle jaune sur les
courts 250 ramasseurs de balles ont été
sélectionnés pour la compétition
retrouve notamment une quinzaine dit
vinoy parmi eux sébastien l'homélie ni à
13 ans licencié au tennis club il monte
un depuis cinq ans il a été retenu pour
la première fois par les organisateurs
ont les gouttes
en fait je voulais être ramasseur de
balle pour voir des grands joueurs voir
des beaux matches
et si on nous classe une occasion unique
je suis quand même fier parce que
on est que à peu près 250 sur 3000 donc
c'est pas beaucoup c'est moins de 1 10e
et surtout on peut voir beaucoup de
joueurs c'est génial sébastien ça a été
un beau rameau surtout la journée voilà
on a bien évolué et surtout la journée
alors me soit plutôt efficace en théorie
donc il a bien la chance quel programme
type d'un ramasseur de balles pendant
une journée à roland garros et ce qu'il
fait un match puis après il rentre chez
lui non pas du tout florane vous trompez
les ramasseurs de balles âgés de 12 à 16
ans arrivent généralement très tôt le
matin entre 7 heures et 8 heures et
repartent le soir vers 21h et réalise au
total quatre à cinq heures de ramassage
par jour avec des rotations toutes les
30 minutes pour pouvoir tenir la cadence
florane il faut donc une bonne condition
physique et surtout maîtriser
parfaitement les gestes techniques du
ramasseur de balles
en fait faut réfléchir avant la fin d'un
point ce qu'il faut faire après le point
donc
et quand tu demandes la balle faut lui
donner simplement on a des balles dans
la main et on les fait rouler
vers les autres ramasseurs les bons
roulés s'est déroulée qui font pas de
rebond et qui sont rapides vont être
ramasseur de balle faut être avoir une
bonne motricité est rapide du vif sur le
terrain avoir une bonne compréhension du
jeu et être efficace sur les roues les
ans et qui sont la technique de base des
rames sur le ballon si on veut voir les
fameux roulé de sébastien goulet les
rouler c'est ça c'est comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent on peut les voir sur quels
cours bas pour le moment sébastien
officiers notamment sur les courts
numéros 16 et 17 depuis le tournoi de
qualification a notamment vu l'espagnol
de 32 go à 32 ans guillermo garcia lopez
mais également les française pauline
parmentier et mathilde johansson
mais le jeune il monte un pointeur et
pourrait être surclassé dans les
prochains jours et notamment aller sur
le court central philippe chatrier où le
suzanne lenglen
comme nous l'expliquent son évaluateur
elles sont notées toute la journée par
les évaluateurs qu'en fin de journée
avec les superviseurs du staff on voit
là on fait un petit récap sûr surtout
les notes et après on les met sur
certains terrains pour le lendemain
l'objectif de ce jeu n'est ni mon teint
de transmettre des ballots numéro un
mondial novak djokovic rafael nadal pour
les quarts de finale où les demies où le
souhaite évidemment de réussir son pari
vous allez le voir dans les prochains
jours florane alors j'ai pas encore la
changez pas eu des billets pour la
quinzaine comme vous et mickey va vous
êtes un peu plus chanceux mais bon si
vous avez un billet en trop voilà
n'hésitez pas non mais vous avez un
panama et des lunettes de soleil
toujours sur moi on verra alors du coup
pour vous aujourd'hui on vous retrouve
attention je retiens ce que vous dit on
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour le
talk et si on parlait sport quel sera le
programme alors avec nos chroniqueurs
nous parlerons notamment de la montée en
nationale 2 du chesnay versailles du
boxeur allant courtois marvin petit qui
combattra sur le ring du cirque d'hiver
souvent on dit à 27 mai mais également
du record d'apnée dandy cabreira on en
avait parlé la semaine dernière mais
c'est vrai un programme toujours
captivant merci beaucoup
michael